JP Morgan says they just got scammed out
of 175 million dollars and it all
centers around them buying the startup
called Frank and its founder Charlie
Javis Frank is a fintech app that's
supposed to help students apply for
financial aid and Charlie wanted to sell
this startup to JP Morgan so she could
make millions but the problem was Frank
only had 300 000 users which was just
not enough if she wanted to sell but
instead of trying to actually get real
customers she decided to just create a
bunch of fake users out of thin air so
Charlie went to a local data science
professor and paid him eighteen thousand
dollars to create four million fake
accounts for her and voila the deal went
through and Charlie became a
multi-millionaire but JP Morgan kept
digging they tried emailing all of those
fake accounts and when all of the emails
bounced back that's when